[موسيقى]
تحت السطح اكتشفت المملكة العربية السعودية
عالماً جديداً على أعتابها ،
أعماق جديدة من الإمكانات غير المستغلة قبالة
سواحل جدة
والبحر الأحمر لم
يمسها أحد ولم يكتشفها حتى الآن ، هذا
مكان لم يكن فيه
سياحة بالفعل لم يكن لدى الناس  فرصة
للزيارة هنا ، كان الأشخاص الذين زاروها
متعمقين تمامًا في أماكن مثل مصر ،
فلماذا لا تأتي إلى مكان يقدم
نفس الشيء إن لم يكن أفضل بسبب
الافتقار إلى السياحة السابقة. Tom Slough
هو عالم أحياء بحرية ومدرب سكوبا
مع  شركة غطس
1760. نشأت هنا يمكنني السباحة قبل أن أتمكن من
المشي
رأيت أول سمكة قرش لي في البحر الأحمر
تغوص مع والدي عندما كان
عمري عامين وأنا مدمن مخدرات منذ
[موسيقى]
رجلين في رحلة الغوص السعوديين.  فحص سلامة الغوص المجاني
لذلك جئنا في الأصل للبحث عن أسماك القرش
وتحول ذلك إلى العثور على مناطق لا تصدق
حيث أننا باستمرار بعض
أنواع الدلافين الشعاب المرجانية البكر التي
نستكشفها سمحت لنا بالوصول حقًا
إلى قلب البحر الأحمر
والتعرف عليها
حصلت على
درجة حرارة مريحة للغوص في
رؤية رائعة ومجموعة متنوعة حقيقية
من الحياة البحرية
هناك مع أفضل ما هناك بعض
المناطق المذهلة من الشعاب المرجانية الصحية
مجموعة متنوعة حقيقية من الحياة البحرية من خلال
أنواع الأسماك لاستشهادات الدلافين
وأسماك القرش الحيتان وجدت تنوعًا أكبر
هنا  من معظم الأماكن في
العالم التي كنت أغوص فيها
لرؤية الدلافين الدوارة ريسوس الدلافين وصدأ
نابليون ، يصل وزن هؤلاء الرجال إلى أكثر من
مترين على الأرجح يبلغ وزنهم 100
كيلوغرام
[موسيقى]
أنا محارب سمكة قرش أحب أسماك القرش ،
لذلك عندما أكون  تعال إلى الخارج ، أحب أن أجد
وأغوص مع أسماك القرش لقد
رأيت أسماك القرش الحريرية وأسماك القرش الحوت وأسماك
القرش النمر وأسماك القرش المطرقة وأسماك القرش التي
أجدها هادئة حول أسماك القرش الغطس
والاحترام المتبادل المفترس إلى المفترس أنا
أفهم حقًا حدود بعضنا البعض
لأن أسماك القرش تتصرف
بلغة الجسد كل شيء  هي لغة الجسد التي
أحب أن أكون معها في نفس الوقت.
مهمة Tom مع 1760 هي أيضًا زيادة
الوعي حول الحفاظ على البيئة البحرية ،
يمكننا أن نبدأها بفهم
الأخطاء التي حدثت في البلدان الأخرى
الآن حيث يوجد غالبًا الكثير من
السياح السياح و  الكثير من
سياحة الغوص ينتهي بك الأمر إلى
تدمير الشعاب المرجانية حتى نتمكن من البدء بسياحة
مستدامة بيئيًا وبدءها
بالطريقة الصحيحة
التعليم هو مفتاح المستقبل لذلك
نحاول حقًا تثقيف الناس
لفهم مدى أهمية نظام المحيطات لدينا الذي
نريده شبابًا  السعوديون الذين يأتون إلى هنا ،
ندربهم ونعلمهم كيف يحصلون على
تقديرهم وحبهم
للمحيطات هناك ، وجعلهم يتولون
دورًا حقيقيًا في تعزيز
والحفاظ على البحر الأحمر قد غير
عقلية الشباب السعودي من خلال منحهم
خيارات وظيفية جديدة مثل ندى.  الرشيد الذي
تحول من الموضة إلى الغطس الحر لقد
تغيرت السعودية في العديد من الجوانب ، ترى
الناس يكتشفون المزيد من الأشياء في
السعودية مثل الفن والرياضة كما أنها
تتحول حقًا أنا
مدرب حر ، أنا أيضًا غواص ولكن
ليس مدربًا
للغوص  يمنحني الصفاء والشعور
بالمغامرة
وأريد حقًا أن يكتشف الناس
المدينة ويشعرون بما أشعر به عندما
ترى الحياة البحرية تشعر
أنك جزء من المحيط
تغوص من الشاطئ فقط ولا حتى
أخذ قارب ترى الشعاب المرجانية الرائعة
ويمكن أن يتراوح العمق من 5 أمتار إلى
100+ ، لذا فهي بيئة رائعة
لكل من الغواصين الأحرار والغواصين ،
كما أنها تجربة
رائعة البحر الأحمر البحر الأحمر مذهل إنه
جميل حقًا إنه لا شيء  لا أطيق
الانتظار لإخراج الأجانب إلى هنا